thanks to surfshark for helping support
this episode
hey crazies from what we can tell our
universe started
in an extremely hot dense state then for
whatever reason
it began to expand and cool off it'll do
this forever it'll do this
until everything is so far apart and so
cold
that nothing will happen anymore how
could something that has an infinite
future have a finite past
maybe it was never finite after all
[Music]
to be clear this is not a mathematical
problem or a measurement problem
it's a philosophical problem when we
look out into the universe and we
account for all the matter
and light within it we find that there
isn't enough for the future we want
using the model of general relativity we
can map out several possible futures and
pasts
some expand and collapse in an endless
cycle
others cool off forever we would like
the cyclical universe to be the one we
live in
it would give the universe new vitality
on a regular basis
active existence would persist forever
unfortunately the data tells a different
story
it says we live in this universe the one
that cools off forever
accelerating as it goes one that ends in
a cold
black void or does it
entropy might have something to say
about this
entropy kind of measures the uniformness
of the energy in the universe
the more uniform things are the less
that can happen
all the gradients the only reason
anything ever happens is because of a
gradient a difference from one place to
another
there are fluid pressure gradients
electromagnetic gradients
time flow gradients and even probability
gradients
they all result in something happening
it would be nice if something could
happen
forever but there's one thing standing
in the way
the second law of thermodynamics it's
the law that ruins
every physics party it says that entropy
in a closed system
tends to increase over time since
entropy
is just a measure of uniformness we can
say that uniformness tends to increase
over time
and since uniformness is the exact
opposite of a gradient
we can say that gradients tend to go
away over time
which is why we say the universe will
end in a cold black void
where nothing happens anymore but
thermodynamics
is based on statistics there are no
guarantees
only trends the second law doesn't say
uniformness must increase
only that it tends to increase so
you're saying there's a chance it could
decrease yes but but only a tiny
itty-bitty chance
consider a room full of air molecules we
expect those molecules to be uniformly
spread
it would be pretty weird if they just
suddenly collected in one corner right
that's because our intuitions are based
on experience and we've never seen that
happen
but statistically speaking it's not
impossible
yes it's highly unlikely and it
certainly wouldn't last long
but it's not impossible in fact how
possible it is
depends on how many molecules there are
in the room
if there are only two molecules in the
room it wouldn't actually be that weird
random motion could easily cause both of
them to be in the corner
if only for a moment it's just that most
rooms don't have
only two molecules they have a crapton
a typical room has on the order of 10 to
the 28 molecules in it
that's 10 000 trillion trillion
this is the kind of scale our instincts
are based on
that's what makes it so unlikely but
statistically it's not impossible
and if you think about it the universe
is kind of like a giant room
a universe is a container with particles
in it particles that obey thermodynamics
if there's a chance all the particles in
a room could end up hot and dense in one
place
then it's possible the particles in a
universe could too
there's a chance the entire universe
could suddenly drop back
into a low entropy state a state with
lots of gradients
a state like it had at the big bang it's
just an extremely small
chance so small that we don't expect it
to happen in any reasonable amount of
time
but what about an unreasonable amount of
time
a monkey randomly typing on a keyboard
wouldn't be expected to type anything
coherent
unless of course they learned english
which isn't unheard of
they're smart little but say you give
the monkey
a lot more time like a year or a million
years
or google years it still wouldn't be
coherent text okay okay how about
a googleplex raised to the googleplex
raised to grams number years
how about then that's a finite number
just a
really big one in that many years our
immortal monkey
might type a coherent page it has become
remotely possible with a large enough
statistical sample
any normally unlikely event becomes
likely
it's called the law of truly large
numbers
if there are enough pages with randomly
typed gibberish
we should expect to see sensible text on
some of them
the library of babel has put this
concept into action
in every room on every shelf in every
book
on every page in this digital library
there is a string of 3200 characters
this library contains every possible
permutation
of 3200 characters chosen from a list of
29
most of the pages look like complete
garbage but if you find
just the right one it might contain the
sentence you're looking for
in the middle of more garbage or all by
itself on a page
or even on a completely sensible page
type in
any word or phrase less than 3 200
characters
and it'll tell you where to find it it's
in there somewhere
probably several places the point is if
we have an insanely large amount of
things
or an insanely long amount of time our
intuition is broken
and the universe appears to have an
infinite amount of time
oh oh oh infinity is the biggest number
right
well yes but also no it depends on what
you mean by number
if you mean an idea we use to count
measure or label the world around us
then it might be reasonable to call
infinity a number
but if you talk to a mathematician
they're gonna be stricter about this
numbers obey certain rules take the
number five for example
if you add another number like three to
it then you get a third number
eight infinity doesn't work like that
if you take infinity and add 3 you'd
expect to get a new number
whatever infinity plus 3 is but you
don't
you just get infinity again it doesn't
obey the rules we expect numbers to obey
and when we
talk about infinity being in the real
world this can lead to some weird
conclusions
given an infinite amount of time our
immortal monkey
wouldn't just be likely to type a
coherent page it would be guaranteed
it would be guaranteed that they'd type
all the works of shakespeare
it would be guaranteed that they type
all the books ever written
in order it's weird infinity
isn't really a number though it's a
concept it's the idea
of endlessness say you've got the full
list of counting numbers
also known as the natural numbers
naturally
our instincts tell us the last number in
the list should be infinity
but it isn't infinity isn't in the list
it's just the idea that the list never
ends
there's a famous thought experiment that
might help us with this it's called
hilbert's hotel
assume the counting numbers represent
all the rooms in an infinite hotel now
assume
all those rooms are occupied by guests
if there are an infinite number of rooms
then there are an infinite number of
guests late one night another guest
shows up and needs a room
unfortunately there aren't any rooms
available right
wrong there's a way to fit another guest
in here
the hotel manager simply has to ask
every guest to move up one room
this frees up room number one for the
new guest
you can do this as many times as you
want to accommodate as many guests as
you need to
even though hilbert's hotel is always
full there's always room for new guests
which kind of breaks our brain there's
no such thing as an infinite hotel
i know i know that this is only possible
because there is no last room
the future is infinite though there is
no last moment
when sets of things are infinite they
break our intuition
space and time are no exception you can
think of space as an
infinite set of points and you can think
of time as an infinite set of moments
space is likely endless in all
directions but
time only seems to be endless in one
direction the future
if we turn the clock back there's a
beginning to everything we know
the big bang the universe has an
infinite future but a finite past
which you know seems a little weird can
you fix it
yes maybe the law of truly large numbers
tells us that
given a large enough statistical sample
any normally unlikely event
becomes likely given an unreasonable
amount of time
we should expect this monkey to type a
coherent page
given an unreasonable amount of time we
should expect all the molecules in this
room
to randomly collect in a corner at least
for a moment the more particles you have
though
the less likely that will be for
particles in a universe-sized room we
might insist there be more than just an
unreasonable amount of time
luckily our universe is expanding
forever into an
infinite future an infinite amount of
time is a lot bigger than an
unreasonable amount of time
probabilities only have meaning in a
finite time
if the future is infinite then anything
that can happen will happen
eventually an immortal monkey randomly
typing all the books ever written
molecules in a room collecting in a
corner and even a universe
collapsing into a low entropy state with
lots of gradients
causing another big bang we just have to
wait long enough for it to happen
randomly
in an infinite space with an infinite
future
big bangs happen randomly in finite
clumps
who knows if our big bang was the first
who knows if there ever was a first
an infinite future guarantees an
infinite past
in an ever-expanding infinite space
[Music]
but you know what isn't infinite
internet access
this video's sponsor surf shark can help
with that
surfshark is a vpn or virtual private
network which adds an extra level of
encryption to your internet experience
of course your data is already encrypted
on all modern websites
if it's got this lock that means your
extremely private data like passwords
and stuff
is protected as much as it can be but
there is
some information that's still accessible
like the urls of the websites you visit
or the internet address assigned to you
by your service provider
while this information could be used by
hackers it's not really worth their time
you're probably not important enough
that information is far more likely to
get used by your service provider to
throttle you
or by advertisers to serve you directed
personal ads
then again maybe you need to bypass some
government censorship
you do you it's none of my business no
matter what you're hiding or who you're
hiding it from
surfsharkvpn can help if you're
interested go to the link in the
description below and enter promo code
asylum
you'll get 83 off and three extra months
for free
which is a good deal it'll also let
surfshark know you heard about them from
me
which helps out the channel so do you
think big bangs can happen randomly in
an infinite future
let us know in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to patreon
patrons brian webber and bosphorus
and youtube members blank n a and
monkeys hq
for all their generous support don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us
and until next time remember it's okay
to be a little crazy wait
wouldn't a random brain be more likely
than a whole universe don't bring that
up
the earth isn't a perfect sphere it's an
oblate spheroid
alright look the difference between the
widest and narrowest parts of the earth
is only 26 miles
the earth is about 7 900 miles across
it's close enough anyway thanks for
watching